[Música]
el futuro pasa por el Ártico
especialmente para Rusia que este martes
inauguró dos nuevos barcos rompehielos
de propulsión nuclear el yakutia listo
para entrar en funcionamiento y el ural
que lo hará pronto
Los buques de una clase tan alta son de
importancia estratégica para nosotros
son necesarios para el estudio y
desarrollo del Ártico para garantizar
una navegación segura y sostenible en
esta región aumentando el tráfico a lo
largo de la ruta del mar del Norte en el
consejo del artículo hay presencia de
ocho países Dinamarca Islandia Noruega
Suecia Finlandia Rusia Canadá y Estados
Unidos casi todos menos Rusia forman
parte de la otan Suecia y Finlandia han
pedido acceso al bloque se cree que en
el Ártico hay un 25% de reservas
mundiales de varios recursos naturales
Mientras que el deshielo causado por la
crisis climática podría abrir nuevas
rutas marítimas hasta semanas más
rápidas
con el derretimiento de la capa de hielo
ha habido una gran discusión entre los
estados árticos y no árticos sobre el
potencial económico todo desde el acceso
a los suministros de energía los metales
y minerales y hasta la apertura de
nuevas rutas de navegación
su control es estratégico y Moscú lleva
la delantera los analistas creen que
occidente necesita 10 años para ponerse
al día con el ejército ruso en la región
Rusia cuenta con infraestructura
portuaria desarrollo tecnológico y
extensión geográfica por lo que trata de
imponer sus propias reglas en la zona
desde antes de 2014 queríamos más
actividad aliada en el norte queríamos
que la otan vigilara también en el norte
tener una vista de 360 grados desde el
Ártico que la otan incluyera el Ártico
Entonces
desde 2005 Rusia reabierto decenas de
bases militares de la era soviética en
el Ártico donde tiene soberanía en más
de 24.000 kilómetros de Costa